what's up everybody welcome to stream
cover back we're back
happy 2017 extremely exciting it's a new
a new year new you a new year same us
hey guys doing baby beige fan what's
going on you're good to see you Michael
sweet what's up Bobby Chung epic woo
that's right we moved the string to
pornhub we did it we moved the stream
2.0 that's where we're at because we're
so sexy you know am I in my new don't be
mad t-shirt today this is a large
sweater we're gonna play a little
battlefield one very exciting for those
of you have not played battlefield one
they did this really fun thing where the
fur the single-player campaign is a
bunch of these little different
campaigns which is pretty exciting so
we're gonna play one of my favorite ones
which is nothing as written that's right
yep even though you don't get to play as
Lawrence of Arabia play you play as a
woman who's this badass
sup guy hey grandma Randa what's up
sailor tin knock Oh oh good this
instantly makes me feel better about
getting out of bed there we go
turn me see us good to see you NR 5 2 to
9 sup yourself sup if you had a note of
that it's soup a lot of people don't
know that soup is delicious here we go
hidden in plain sight there's like
sneaking around in this one and there's
some explosions and [ __ ] it's gonna be
fun I'm terrible with this game by the
way thank you to Xbox for getting us
these amazing elite controllers first
I'll feel heavy this is also we gave
away a lot of these we gave away a lot
of these at Christmas
here we go Mesopotamia spring 1918 Great
War engulfs the globe and the deserts of
the Middle East Arab tribes rebelled
against our historical press without I'm
a tenth part account of the uprising the
Ottomans to play the most advanced
technologies never stamie agility and
there's busy a giant death train
basically can Lawrence of Arabia hello
oski gwaan good to see you apathy 26mm
you're where can I send some items for
you guys what's the
fan what's the fan address hit him with
that fan address I think answer us
where's Conan right now he's in his
office preparing for today's show
hello from Italy hello Matteo what's
going on hey what's up Shirl in scorched
some big rocks oh don't we know it
nice virtue of elite will be released
this year sister on 27 - also they have
this has a whole thing back here now if
you can see it but you can you plug in
like other buttons you can be like get
all that guy like a crab or something
underneath there you know I saw someone
made the point that like crabs are such
like [ __ ] because it's like dude you
live in the ocean and you still walk
everyone else is swimming and not only
do you walk you walk sideways
yeah that's pretty dark
it's like fu evolution it's terrible
yeah well we're not Lawrence of Arabia
we're a woman who's a more of a badass
well a lot that's a lot of smiley faces
whoever did that thank you all right
this is us look at this I have totally
forgotten how to play this game there we
go we're gonna mark our bad guys the key
to this game is marking guys I can't
overstate that enough anymore fellas
over there
this elite controller is gonna take a
little getting used to
he says as an excuse for one yeah we are
gonna play this on multiple later today
if you guys have it we'll play with you
Oh be awesome I have please I get
murdered so quick on multiplayer so let
we'll get murdered single-player and
then we'll get murdered multiplayer here
we go
I got my knife ready to go
sexiness unless you're me in which case
you're gonna be very seen all the time
under the rooftop hatch all right
name it a song I don't know that song
shoot him Finlay we can't shoot people
yet although that is my mode of death
that's what I like to do I get in there
I caught some ruckus we're gonna go on I
think I'm gonna do a flanking maneuver
right snow day the key to this game is
shoot everybody fast
I agree American mystery hey happy near
yourself McGary how do I do the thing
where oh it's this okay I got to figure
out that you throw like a little coin or
something we are playing xbox one today
on our new elite controllers which are
badass and congratulations to the folks
who want them from us hoping we'll be
doing a lot more giveaways in the future
you're gonna die multiplayer you're
right something cancer so you can talk
about the new format for clueless gamer
and need details hahaha I know we do
with you guys have something to watch
when we're in reruns actually that's
what's called that's what's called
striking a nerve
where's our boss state database our boss
is upstairs right now
I try to syringe kill No
how do I do that I love the idea of that
oh yeah all right in the heart yeah but
you know what sometimes attention is
just what we need
what is your gamertag oh yeah what is
the game protect it's just Blair Blair's
my last name which is impossible to
spell so do I just run for that dude you
could just get that gun and just mow
everybody down maybe that's the move
what do you think oh this orig thing you
plays like I drop a gun you can use that
let's go
oh god I suck at this Jesus Christ Blair
oh well looks like I gotta take that gun
please
hi could I get that gun thank you
this isn't going so well for me I'm not
screwed I'll show you this guy screwed
Wow I certainly am floating this Jesus
Christ alright I get them with me show
you for behind there's got to be some
cool stuff in here right oh come on a
silencer you dicks oh yeah that's what I
needs a wrench
they're shooting guys Florenz would be
ashamed no he would he's not gonna be
ashamed
he likes results the results is what I'm
gonna gets gets BRB gotta kill some
dudes oh I like this guy
you can't tell me I didn't hit that guy
all right Jesus oh there's a grenade
behind me
although I did kill those guys do you
think those guys done with me Oh Zahraa
Blair is a common last name insulting
Kurt Jahnke best gave at 2016 I thought
was inside I love that played it here
Firewatch is great all right all these
guys already tagged alright new idea I'm
gonna go down on the left I think we
have to take that dude out is basically
the idea alright let's try it again here
we go alright oh wait this dude - what's
that guy he's our guy down here
somewhere unseen yet very loudly whoops
hey buddy you dropped all your blood on
the ground go pick it up okay now now
that we got ourselves a gun what do we
do next
he's not trustful to be on the live
stream hello Weezer what's up my hands
are always sweaty JJ do play the sand
pirate abduction I know I'm a played
abduction with that goat simulator very
fun
have we seen Wes world I have seen Wes
world didn't look like anything to me
haha thank you up top uh yeah although
you know what I follow I was a member of
the I followed reddit and don't read the
reddit Westworld they nailed it all I
mean congratulations like those folks
are really smart but ruin completely
ruin the show for me so I just kill this
dude first or what I'm going in for sure
I don't do that sneaking around crap
and then kill and nice this guy real
quick
goddess gunfire so slow Jesus
okay get me I'm in a ditch just run my
money here's my battlefield if you could
put like my battlefield a strategy and a
gift it would just be this loaded up oh
come on
this gun is berries
that guy sucks dude killing me bro
shooting me through the thing that's
aggressive very aggressive I don't
appreciate
yeah this is gonna be fun
let's sneak up on his ass how bummed
were the final fantasy people after
Conan's playthrough they were really
excited they thought it was really funny
they loved it actually like that's the
thing is like you kind of couldn't see
out of the hall but they're all just
laughing hysterically that's something
like everybody you know they have
they're just happy that they want people
to just play the game they're really
excited about the game where's that guy
who was up here oh well well well this
is the gun that I wanted this is one of
my favorite guns in the game
that it do we do the thing oh we got to
go in the hatch get to the choppa hey
mridu be uh yeah it was really fun they
they actually really liked it they
thought it was great and that was all by
the way unplanned like 100% off-the-cuff
which is like my favorite stuff that
happens oh come on dude yeah shut up
alright I fell down I don't need you
saying like parables and what you know
like Oh someone is asking about the
Makonnen blade did he appreciate the
historical aspect uh he did perfect just
like I'm appreciating them now uh yeah I
mean yeah he did he he was absolutely
excited to play this game and he was
really looking forward to it final
fantasy he was a little afraid yeah but
this game he was really looking forward
to I had to get a really good time what
is my deal dude I'm terrible um the
Brioni content here at which is always
my nightmare the broadcaster may hate
the game but you know what here's the
thing I think that hmm I don't know I
kind of feel like you know part of it is
like they video game companies I mean
the thing is like Conan is clueless he
has no credibility so it truly doesn't
matter whether or not he hates the game
or if he loves it
because he he's an idiot when it comes
to video games so I think that's that's
where like we are very lucky in that
respect because it kind of doesn't
matter
they contemplate Dragonball Z oh man I
love Dragon Ball Z I have a trunks
figure self figure and vegetal
is a vegetative Rize figure I'm all
about Dragon Ball Z I'm ready for the 4k
remake in the Atari et exactly angel
groves at least watch you try to make
the jump is entertaining
whoo sake the tables have turned bald
man look at this guy leave it to old
Larry of Arabia I call him Larry to make
an interest good old Larry
Nathan vlogs he noticed me I noticed in
2017 I've started doing this when
someone says something that I agree with
it's a high fiving I just go hey
anything about that I just got like a
and then I just step back so say
something say something that I'd agree
with somebody something that I like be
back at work is dope what I said
something I like I'm sorry you take my
advice don't be bad anyway so I'd be
like oh yeah that's my new 2017 guys
2016 I didn't high-five people I did
tingles so I'd be like but then you try
to do some tingles to a girl at the club
and it's really creepy really quickly
she's like get away from you don't touch
me through weird gross sweaty fingers so
now I'm just like oh talk about my fave
[Music]
it's kind of like a fake like it's a
fake kung fu fight I don't know
Aran's stam I don't know what that means
I am clue yeah
casual tan who that guy has a nasty
paper cut in his face don't do that
modified font
Hey
you should have been a dank meme man it
was the twinkles it's the tingles at the
twinkles
it's horrible Aaron don't do that what
do you mean hi Courtney
yeah the armored train isn't
historically accurate but it is pretty
dope
please beer goggles tickles 2016 yeah
here's the thing VIX 14 I love Taco Bell
del Taco is great too but I grew up on
talked about so it's near and dear to my
heart it's so good Oh God just classic
kanji they're cold the cold cheese and
the crisp lettuce and the warm meat with
mostly soy in it who started debt
started Debbie just goes comment comment
comment very meta for 2017 well clueless
gamer continue Andres wolf of course
it'll continue until long after I'm dead
in three months let's be honest I'm not
gonna last until summertime can i play
with you yes professor buttons you can
play with me
dad I don't get the damn thing I don't
understand it it's just somebody sees
something sneezing oh stop yes touch of
red I believe you already thought
through which games would be dope to
play during this comic-con no I have it
I'll explain you games what games should
be played right now nothing beats the
burgers at stake no buns ketchup mustard
nothing just burgers and steak brain
typhoon you're speaking my language more
steak in 2017 rip Aran yeah back on the
ps3 so this username gamer stuff got it
dab is not good agreed oh it's a drug
thing got it I'm not a big drug guys
know what I am a big tequila guy my drug
of choice is sadness as in when you try
to talk to girls it doesn't go I
wouldn't say soothing I went out on my
birthday on Saturday night with two
other people my friends Dave and Jen and
just
is awful but you know it was great is I
got a big rubber fish my friend team so
we were just like playing with this
rubber fish at this club we're at this
like Club this place called the Virgil
which is like a speakeasy slash dance
party thing and we were there like half
of its a speakeasy and then the other
half that's like a dance party thing and
I can't explain to you how quickly girls
run away when you have a giant rubber
fish in your hand it's impossible for me
to explain it it's as if you're just
like farting all night you might as well
just be like crop-dusting the entire
night aren't you glad you guys all tuned
into this stream koko whoops whoops
dirty look at that by the way I love
like they put like dust devils in this
game so cool so we're gonna we have to
recon three strongholds and basically
beat the ball and also if I remember
correctly oh yeah they're these a-holes
on a frickin this thing going on over
here a tank which is danger town
so anyway we were like part of the
challenge of the night was who could get
the rubber who could get up on stage
with the rubber fish that was the
challenge and Dave did it so kudos to
Dave we just at one point we looked over
he just see a rubber fish being waved
and we're like ah I've been anyway if
you want to not get a girlfriend or a
boyfriend
bring a rubber fish to the club so do
guys by the way by the way everybody
does everybody does then we played a fun
game called kiss the fish so you can
figure out what that's about
kiss the fish baby we're strategy we
need as a singing fish as pre mounted on
a wall and then prepared lines for
making fun of it I have it I have one of
those
Meister I 42 you should play the
campaign the campaign is great at
Battlefield it's super fun these puns
sambuca you can't do sambuca doesn't say
Moo calves like stuff floating in it
like what coffee beans from I'm making
that up what is that that I'm thinking
of what's the thing with little coffee
beans float in it somebody say that was
like kombucha kombucha kombucha no I'm
not thanking boba tea although I've had
boba tea
you got to chew it back it's real weird
it's all these like little like things
in there all right what do I have in
terms of switch we played it it was
really fun yeah
eliminate the commander all right I'm
not really warmed up guys I'm just gonna
put that out there so you know it's not
the commander up there now let's kill
that dude I always take out the lookouts
first Pikachu
sarcasm shoot something look dude I'm
sneaking around all right
God you guys are bloodthirsty don't
worry you know what there is gonna like
shits about to go down at about the
minute first we gotta do a little recon
this is how you do it you want to be
surprised when you're running from giant
tanks through a the ruins kneel in that
deed
he's looking over he's looking over he's
looking over he's looking over he's
looking over nope nope nope
since when is sneaking games Touche
promise I really want to just stab this
guy in the heart cuz it's fun to stab
people in the heart come after you with
your mother
I could actually she would love that
don't let my mom here probably was my
mom we said that you're my favorite
segment show all thanks gene plays games
can I'll thank you
I love Poland oh it's just gonna work
how fast can I get up the ladder yeah
girl you so sexy when you're dead this
is the kind of stuff I shouldn't say to
people in real life you're so sexy when
you're not the club's definitely not at
the club's all right let's go do some
damage I have a feeling the S is gonna
hit the F Oh see this is the problem we
got to stop that thing we hate that
something I'm gonna kill that dude well
that didn't work out
crap oh Jesus no [ __ ] oh boy oh this is
really bad
wow this is this is dumb oh Jesus Christ
oh boy
well I've managed to kill exactly no one
ah and now they're shooting me with a
giant tank all right let's get in don't
be mad bro don't be mad oh that's bad
why I'm like a Thai some kind of a tank
gun or something where's my grenades
I don't have any grenades you gotta be
kidding me there's no burn aids well
let's go in here this show some kind of
anti-tank situation stick grenades fine
I really need is like something that
kills tanks limpet charge oh those are
the worst
yes anti-tank grenade that's what we
want okay
all right tank where you at bro I got
something for you baby
oh you're right there
let's try it again Jesus Christ okay
that didn't go very well
oh boy oh they're really into some
trouble now we are I like to call
totally screwed it's a scientific term
when in doubt run away that's what I do
oh that's like an armored guy great
that's cool
I could just kill one dude that would be
great great Misha Collins okay well
and it's not gonna work at all is it
nope okay that guy's got some serious
armor on I need is like what just
happened to the regular oh I took
grenades great throw flare
I do anything I got it huh
oh that's is that the tank is this
Conan's couch this is the couch they
used we had in New York on so who's sat
on this couch Louie CK sat on this couch
oh boy oh that's the tank let's kill
this guy who else doubt on this couch
Ryan Reynolds sat right we're back to
sitting I'm dying I'm dead nope I'm good
that guy can just eat oh I got the
message
Tracy Morgan was on this couch who else
was on this couch Andy Richter also on
this couch oh we have 51 bullets left
let's get rid of this dumb gun I hate
this gun okay oh boy that's sounded oh
boy there it is
oh there's so many guys over there oh
Jesus Christ
you know what let's just dispatch the
message oh and I just ran into the tank
dope dope yep yep yep yep oh oh just
shells whizzing by on the one time one
day morning let's go bro let's do a
little thing come on cardio man let's go
you know what maybe I'll make a run for
that thing Jesus making a run for it
there's got to be some kind of tank
busting stuff in here now I feel like a
celebrity yep give me something good in
here dude oh boy that's bad that was
like a direct hit where is the tank
Jim do I just what do I do
it's nice shooting me let's get some
higher ground
Oh that was real close ah there's a
frickin sniper over there you know what
to complete this little game
give me just one second to recover here
go there we go all right and take a
charge let's do it run in a zigzag
pattern not like the kid from Game of
Thrones zigzagging zigzag up and pop pop
pop yep that's bad okay Jesus Christ oh
this is hard to watch I know I'm sorry
Michaels we come on I'm sorry windsock
don't kill the bird bro
fly
nailed it objective complete in your
face tank
don't be mad baby yeah yeah I know okay
alright let's lure the tank yeah yeah we
gotta kill this tank my sensitivity
I'm but I'm a sensitive guy yeah alright
let's try it
anything to help me if you have any any
tips that would really help it's pretty
low dude I mean isn't that low soldier
zoom sensitive is that we want cone is
terrible on battlefield corrupt he's
always terrible Scott man good to see
you black hmm Lord stood raised I don't
know advanced run here's a tip by a scuf
controller with that here we go
yeah the Randy the Randy Johnson pitch
by the way have you seen that that
YouTube video or Randy Johnson the big
unit like the pitcher throws a fastball
and it hit a bird birds with it it just
turns into feathers it's like a cartoon
oh there's two tanks oh that explains
why I'm so screwed okay here we go ready
there are two tanks is that possible
Jesus Christ all right I think we're
gonna let's back up put it down run away
did they kill the horse I need that
horse okay you know what
all all is not lost all is not lost
never all right we got two tanks very
few bullets
here's we're gonna do we're gonna let
the other two tankers just one really
quick tank it just be one let that tank
look for us
that's right keep looking [ __ ] keep
looking not over there yep exactly
nope run
kids it's so important to recon your
tanks this is why now so far I haven't
been able to kill a single person with
the sniper rifle so it's basically
useless to me I want to do is get to the
weapons over there man
when I get dem weapons kill it tank
where's it at
there is another one isn't there it's
beautiful out tonight yeah wonder if
they actually put constellations up
there but you they did these guys think
of everything
well that tank is being a little [ __ ]
over there which they give up searching
and place stealthy make them more ruined
it is a killing machine Andy you're
right you know what so am i all right
here we go there's got to be something
here that can kill a tank there's gotta
be there's just gotta be what is this
what did I pick up well well well if it
isn't a pickaxe I need a pickaxe oh well
if it isn't an anti-tank grenade
someone's in big big trouble
it sounds gonna cool yet frustrating job
having to place every I don't know every
I've been to have to place every star in
the night sky I bet all they did was
just like use a map right earth-like
somebody's made a map of the night sky
they just probably you know Google
search JPEG high-quality yeah
slap it in there that's what that's what
your boy would do and your boy meaning
me I refer to myself is your boy oh well
well well
a rocket gun eh don't mind if I do
what is this thing Lewis gun suppressive
great I'll take that what else we got in
here I don't care about silencer
alright yep I just got it
you boys got a rocket gun don't be mad
here we go oh I'm gonna blow this [ __ ]
out of this thing other games I don't
suck at no Blake there are no games I
don't suck at
how do I aim this gun and why won't it
aim right now I have to be all the way
on the ground that's right all right
here we go you ready Oh can't wait for
this
after you laying down to use it here we
go candy crush I suck at Oh sucks for
you yeah bring it
let's not get run over by the thing dude
Jesus Christ all right all right it's a
rocket gun it can't kill a tank come on
all right fine
worthless can't shoot through rocks can
you miss me here we go
just for God's sakes throw the stupid
thing at it
Oh Mike come this way zigzag pattern
thank you finally my god
and it's still shooting at me that's
cool you're gonna shoot again
give me a jerk about it yep I knew it
today
oh man I threw it over the stupid fake
players you dumbass
well I'm considering that at Wayne
because I can't follow me so whatever
let's keep going
rocket gun Oh worthless I take it a
bunch more bullets though for my
favorite gun the old Nancy death-dealer
I call it the Nancy death-dealer I do
throw grenades like a girl I know sorry
pp touch our 911 sorry about that
alright let's do something a little more
fun just murder these guys now I know
it's
[Music]
thanks for the memories
oh I hit him come on
why do I even try you know what's the
point of even trying
alright well kill those dudes I hate the
stupid sniper rifle I should probably
keep it though what's up with this thing
huh
blow it up rocket guns out of ammo
alright well forget it then
uh alright on the next one
Amy behind the head potato head yeah
seriously perfect sample star barf you
know what I saw I must have been called
fart barf alright you guys haven't seen
far barf they're great highly recommend
them far apart is great probably got to
be sensitive with a joystick treat it
like a girl so don't touch it you know
what I don't need is your pretentious
talking I don't unpack speed and
mobility unless I'm driving I think what
he means by the way that took all night
it's literally daytime let's go over
here and kill these mofos fart barf is
not surfer Punk fart bark is like
crunchy discotheque no alright I'm gonna
get off my horse here
let Beth play no not good at video games
all right we got eight bullets let's
make it eight kills you know let's get
up somewhere let's binocs but knock it
up
so far I see no one maybe this town's
deserted you know everything about that
maybe they just forgot to put bad guys
in this level
well there's well no bad guys well I can
see your shadow
so crunchy it stays crunchy and milk
always baby someone said hey you are the
dude that insulted my girlfriend a
nightclub in Berlin I didn't insult
anybody in any nightclub nuke hi Berlin
hello Berlin good to see you as it was
said they heard you had a rubber fish
and they left callback callback that's
right that's a great yeah
the thing is people were not offended by
the fish they were just like you're a
weirdo like get out of here you don't
I'm saying the fish just didn't do me
any favors I didn't offend anybody this
is a good someone was asking does TE
Lawrence have an estate that design
often something like this or any movies
I would imagine so right because T
Lawrence is a real person yeah and I
think real people yeah absolutely
and also like yeah I'm sure like the
light like the portrayal yeah life
rights all that stuff they're like no
bad guys here this is great
he says is he swarmed with bad guys a
little nervous there's nobody around
close cameras awesome Thank You J shank
oh hello from Pakistan
well hello Pakistan I was in Berlin
though yes I was there during the you
see the dominatrix remote conan made me
stand outside in the hallway there's a
bad guy well I've seen one bad guy here
oh I hate that dude how you blow that
dude up should we try it what about if I
did you just make a blow-up noise with
your mouth no that's just what could I
shoot him sneaky sneaky about it
is there another dude right there no
that's the vase
Conan's the least funny guy on the
planet the least there's so many people
on the planet though yeah all the whole
planet I mean I think then that would
mean he would come back around and be
really funny yeah
they'd be like wow you're so stunningly
not funny that it has me yeah exactly
alright here we go I'm gonna take a shot
at this dude you gotta blow up his tank
though I think I got a weekly turns
around
Fireman guy he's funny by accident there
you go
it's every game have wallhack mode these
days what's wallhack mode what does that
mean Blake snowflake pyromania oh is
that what that means like a Sims thing
here we go watch me
guys watch how badly I messed this up
Oh got him kablooie
now what if they're gonna know that I'm
up here nobody saw me right oh I see
what you mean
yeah you're right I bet I could turn
that off that we you know what's the fun
of watching them then try to find me oh
look at that guy right there
let's wallhack that guy
I kind of had somebody crawl up here so
I can just knife them in the throat
there they go back to their sad lives
you know the huge stir up the pot you
know the huge jug lift good to see you
Oh bro Oh bro Oh bro
good luck of my Japanese nightclub what
does I mean am i starting a Japanese
nightclub that I don't know about what's
my favorite snack when playing video
games his jungles my favorite snack I
mean a car cheat Cheetos is like
literally my favorite food
crunchy Cheetos you know like lose you
know cut maybe I'll crawl up here
scrunchy cheetah as I say then he gets
all over the controller so then you just
gotta throw the controller way I go
through a lot of different controllers
like two a week punch it Mikey
caviar love you the Leggett 171 our
biggest scrub is pretty fun actually it
really takes the pressure off yes you
know I have to worry about things from
your scrub you know uh we're not playing
Witcher 3 madam maniac up here he comes
please come up here
I want to tag one more dude before I get
off this thing
Ichi does the chopsticks I didn't
respond uh sky flame 300 I think they
found me out
hope nobody crawls up this ladder to
their death bring Jordan
here they come here they come
can I just stay up here no one could pop
me right oh whoops forgot about grenades
shoot him in the crotch whenever
possible
ah Jesus Christ yikes get me off this
roof be badass reloading wild falling
off a building
you sure
how was it dark again I thought it was
dealing then whoops forgot about
grenades
famous last words is 2.2 all this dude
is dead
you know I like to shoot him in the
crotch just to intimidate them you know
then it like lets other guys know maybe
I shouldn't leave that dude alone just
shooting everybody in the crotch
oh my crotch gets shot I do love in
these games like when the music stops
you know you're out of trouble this
girls taking so many bullets of cuz of
me that's true you taking out like a
champ though
[Music]
are you going there buddy team Coco you
noticed me would be a good segment bring
sled guests on for a bit of gaming great
idea how old is this channel assist you
could robot that's a great question a
year year and a half that's how old I am
emotionally that helps
Thank You Juan go have some drinks yeah
yeah yeah feel this is turning into the
forest how so do I want it I guess I do
want to take this right this little gun
I mean a sniper rifles probably better
let's keep this sniper rifle sniper
rifle sucks sometimes you know guys it's
someone wieldy all right where am I
going now I gotta go this way send this
message out it's good semester [ __ ] just
team deathmatch I'm not used to seeing
this game outside Congress no ah I'm in
this barbed wire f I know this is single
player single player is great at the
campaign you can jump all around to
different to different players it's
really fun that's okay Jay shank 21 just
keep keep keep adding in no star bar we
have celebrities on this channel also
we've had Roman reigns we've had the
Trailblazers we've had a bunch of people
we had Freddie Prinze jr. we had mr.
fred durst from the biskits we've had a
lot of folks John carnage from twitch
yeah mr. twitch himself so yes we do
have we have and we have a bunch of had
the Evil Dead cast that's right ash vs.
Evil Dead Green draymond Green was here
playing video games with us haha so yeah
we've had a ton of great folks come by
and yes we will have more folks come by
in the coming weeks
considering Roman reigns a celeb
windsock what do you mean how dare you
oh that's white words WWE Champion watch
your mouth windsock
that's right here you know what here's a
great you want to see a great
behind-the-scenes photo of Terry Crews
say great it never made never made air
but I'll show you because you guys are
watching and you deserve to see behind
the scenes stuff from my phone this is
how high-tech we are here let's see here
hold on one second oh if this phone
could talk actually it probably can
let's see yeah boy Terry Crews this
photo oh no I gotta find this Terry
Crews photo I'm such a jerk
we'll find it oh no no no no it's I
didn't put it up it's a it literally is
on my phone there's some Wiz Khalifa
photos here's a Wiz Khalifa here's me
here's me taking a photo of Conan Wiz
Khalifa there you go
wait where's the Terry Crews photo
there's a large wood well I can't find
it
well I promise the Terry Crews photo no
I can't find it who's the jerk I'm the
jerk everybody it's not a mystery oh
well no I didn't put it on Instagram
did I seriously where is it that's crazy
well I'm a dick guys I'm the worst sorry
about that I'm gonna keep looking for
one more second and then we're just
gonna play some more
seriously where is it there's bunny he's
got so many bunny photos
huh all right I can't find it that's
crazy
everyone's just like they hate this yeah
they must die
I'm actually shocked I thought it was on
air I'm sorry everybody
well anyway well you have to see Wiz
Khalifa photo it's that photo Griff
whatever run the jewels sorry thank you
for well just just wait just wait till I
start playing it's about to get way less
professional Turk Rousset dream there
never was a photo you're right any buds
it's on here somewhere
I give my phone to bet that there's so
many dick pics on here of other people
send me dick pics sorry I'm just gonna
with one hand run towards the other
stronghold and what the other hand look
for this photo there's run the jewels
that was fun
Warren Ellis wouldn't it be my downloads
this is what I get for having it Oh guys
actually quick Taco Bell thing I went to
Vegas and they have the Taco Bell
Cantina there's only four of them in the
world one of them's in Vegas and they
have a full bar they have menu items you
can't get anywhere else
this has just turned into a plug for
talk about because I love Taco Bell but
check this out this is what's on the
inside look at this look at this those
are all alcoholic slushies each one is a
different flavor of slushie are you
seeing this you guys seen this it's
amazing and then upstairs
they have crazy there's like a nightclub
it's incredible it might be the best the
best thing I've ever experienced I swear
to god there's a photo of me handing
bunnies out to Terry Crews on here
alright well we'll end the hour with
that
on a Buchan Nezzer dude you look oh
thank you so much talk about drunk food
no wrong it's sober food it's delicious
food also I just like to point out I had
my birthday Denny's have you haven't
been to Denny's in a while they
rebranded and it's amazing
danny's is incredible whole page of
slams now it's unbelievable
crap Aronoff don't taco about it oh well
done lost in translation you get the pun
award for 2017 talk about disgusting
you're wrong it's delicious BRB going to
Vegas it was so fun they have a full bar
it was they have Taco Bell swimsuits you
can buy it's the best it is literally
the best it's so fun it's right on the
strip it's right by Planet Hollywood
who doesn't love Denny's I agree
alright you know what I'm sick of this
let's just running kill some people oh
you know what first i'm gonna disable
the alarm you took too long
stabbed in the heart no I don't need
this guy this is gonna be bad for me
isn't it patience is a virtue friends
Oh shite well this just went very bad
most out of bullets
whoo I'm very almost dead let's just
take a quick breather
pause commercial break we all want food
sorry guys Slayer Darth we're back today
from hiatus we got boots I'll show today
Viggo Mortenson Emily Heller love Emily
the great frien Poe Seine quick story
about Viggo Mortensen I back in New York
City when I lived there
load back in New York City you should
work for McSweeney's which is a small
literary imprint by the great Dave
Eggers and Viggo Mortensen came by and
read some of his poetry which was really
great this is right after I think he was
done filming Lord of the Rings and we
all went drinking with Viggo Mortensen
like six of us and Viggo and he was the
nicest dude ever not only was he the
nicest dude ever he like remembered my
name like I went to the bathroom I came
out he's a hair was gone I was like
Viggo he's the man he wouldn't know me
now obviously but it was so cool he's
like the most down-to-earth humble and
by the way great poet there you go
look up some of his poetry but it was
really really cool it's a really really
great experience very I'll never forget
that and then he was in like Laura and
then he was in the Lord of the Rings and
blew up and so it was like unbelievable
guys you always love to see really nice
people do well
oh and also he paid for everyone's I
mean ah
PBOT everyone drinks the entire night so
goes without saying but I thought I'd
say it anyway cuz I know some of you
know he didn't know he didn't headbutt
me by the Lafon he chipped a tooth the
Lord of the Rings and glued it back on I
know he's a man
he was nice but also nice you've never
eaten from Taco Bell weatherman breeding
shoes with tortillas there we go
homemade Taco Bell PvP Daniel Gonzales
maybe so maybe we should quit playing
after last half-hour is your place and
multiplayer your birthday can give a
shout-out ninja ninja REO ninja re there
you go
Snoke oh go to Taco Bell Melissa Kay oh
my god
yeah I get knocked out all the time oh
man my go to a Taco Bell you know I'm a
fan of the classics I like I like that
you know hardshell tacos are delicious
I'll do just regular bean burrito which
is good I like those when I went to the
Taco Bell Cantina I got quesadilla
nachos chicken strips and some other
things and they're the chicken strips
were pretty good Castillo nachos were
dead
ah goodbye gorilla Reaper Doritos Locos
are great I don't like too many of those
though you know it's I like it as a
treat I you know what I like a Mexi melt
I like to tostada when they had the
pizza that was great yeah Slayer Darth
what what what's a bad Vigo movie I
don't know oh my god
Eastern Promises is crazy that fight
scene is insane so good Mexican food is
delicious and so is talking about blue
stick nachos haven't had him wait a
second meatless Kovic what are you doing
eating steak nachos we found you out
Shawshank yeah you need help with
Shawshank you need help with homework
hit us up that's really smart
I'm really dumb but I'm wearing glasses
it's going good Razi poo talk about
there is talk about KFC's here yeah
Chris Milwaukee Co have talked about
tell us what you think over are they the
double deckers great Ethiopian food is
really good there was a Venezuelan place
HD at at New York all the time that was
also really good yeah oh yeah yes
so basically weird try there's this
giant killer death machine tank but the
bad guys have that we need to take down
and it's headed our way
and basically what's happening is that
Lawrence of Arabia is saying I'm gonna
go try to get people to help you but you
might be all on your own
to kill this tank I need to kill this
tank train train tank tank train and our
little I love it
get the multiplayer on compelled me with
my coding so I think we can beat this
should we do this we're gonna beat this
then we'll play some multiplayer I have
no I'm kind of screwed here all right
you know what I've never been good at
being quiet but let's do our best
this is gonna help us later so we don't
get surprised how that guy sucks I'm
gonna shoot that guy with a rocket gun
mark my words
there's a lot of bad guys gotta do your
homework kids that's a big gun there's a
horse
my god all right
[Music]
welp do we play with other streamers we
have we have as soon as I beat this
level we're gonna play some multiplayer
so let's get to the killing shall we
I'm gonna kill that guy first cuz that
guy Oh
casual tan oh great I got the tiniest
gun there is
you let them just wait for them to come
to me
you're gonna find like a real gun oh my
god
well this may take a couple lives Jesus
Christ
I think I got those guys though let's
try it again shall we I am terrible
touch of red kick their ass seabass is
it Conan visiting his Secretary's
country
it was his assistant Sonam obsession and
he already did
it was Armenia oh they're already after
me oh cool
bring it on mofos
[Music]
Jesus God
I need somebody else's freaking gun man
better join all these guns
well I tried to shoot that guy in the
dick didn't work new idea let's run in
to the let's run into the town see if we
can get away get some distance on these
dudes you know as long as I'm here right
I Nina's like a shotgun or something you
know I need a different gun oh here we
go
oh great oh I need a freaking different
gun brah Oh is there a different gun
please alright well let's see
completely x' now is it less cool when i
screemed cook Bloomie's that's cool
right
that's like Saving Private Ryan I know
it's the wrong war but what's a war well
Dunkirk is set in World War one
they shot Dunkirk in the stage next to
us soccer surfer Nolan in a full wetsuit
it was pretty dope and I saw
what's-his-face coming out of the
bathroom Harry from one direction he's
really tall by the way yeah I saw him
come on to the bathroom across from the
studio
yeah like did his hair it was really
funny and he was in like a World War one
outfit it's pretty dope
and they shot it in the stage next to us
because there's a huge water tank there
so is this huge I mean you probably
guessed cuz Christopher Nolan doesn't
normally directly come in a wetsuit
objective complete oh yeah give me this
thing right rifle grenade hey oh come on
bro these are rifle grenade oh my god
it's so dude I need your gun man your
gun I hate this sniper rifle where's
your gun ah ah Jesus oh boy well guess
what you can't stab a guy who's wearing
armor be wise open eyes it has been a
long time it's felt like a long break
years ago literally it's a world war two
movie Dunkirk isn't hey sit
no dunkers it is World War two yeah what
was I thinking of this World War one
can I kill this guy
oh geez
yeah yeah yeah shoot him up laugh it up
fuzzball oh I saw broke one it was great
this is very end of road one ish oh boy
there's a lot of shooting going on
well your boy needs is another gun I
know I keep screaming about it but if I
just had one machine gun I really could
put a hurtin on these guys you know
these soldiers are pretty
Wow somebody's pissed off
I'll take this gun whatever it is or
yeah
where you at Holmes take you longer load
stab sucks for you
somebody shoot me freakin mortars at me
alright mortar boys gotta go you know
what are you confused about windsock I
think I wrote one I loved I thought it
was great I didn't it was really fun I
thought it's very beautiful I thought
Gareth Edwards did a great job of the
direction there's that one scene
well one shot of like a Star Destroyer
coming out of the dark space like a
shark and I was like oh my god
rad it's beautiful I mean it was really
cool of course Vader great it's awesome
is that Mordechai up here hey you the
mortar yeah how's that feel huh kid
mortar me
you shooting me are you I love those
like explosions going on I have no idea
I can't see any explosions I don't see
any guy shooting at me oh wait wait I
take that back
found the guys shoot at me oh that's
cool
I've never fired a mortar before in this
game I'll get him get him get him that
was great
rooftop hookah all right
not again until 2004 I heard somebody
told me that the Cubs winning the series
like has screwed the NFL so badly it was
so exciting yet
oh I got that guy I didn't get that guy
come on oh boy oh goodness
yeah what now
yup stupid idiot
I hate you sorry yeah how's that feel
you know I should just why do I even
need a gun in this game just give me a
knife give me a knife and a good pair of
Nikes or knife keys like put my knives
in my Nikes tea baguette yep ball
blaster who else wants a knife to the
throat
anybody want a close shave what is
happening better not be a mortar I'm
gonna be very upset okay we got more
grenades what's in here something I
can't use probably there's a grenade in
here that's cool rifle grenade no what
is this I have that
I'll take it Oh God what is with the
scoped weapons in this game a few dude
let's blows I hate all these guns great
oh boy here we go last level
yeah windsock there is a shotgun in this
game but it's really hard to get 360
noscopes give me a knife in nice knife
keys this is it kiss this over 38 Nike
is Nike you don't call your bike Mikey
what is it just called Mike how are you
supposed to say it destroy the armored
train okay
I feel like easier said than done let's
go let's kill this train what's in here
oh you know what I'm going to take 85
deaths a challenge accepted
oh it's pointed at me
Jesus yeah there we go got that thing oh
yeah I'll take this I'll take this I'll
take this let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go kill it kill it kill
it
damn it that's death one it's Greek it's
more like Niq Niq a is it nikkei no one
calls those shoes nee K's Nike their
Nikes guys are nuts
greetings to Germany what's up big nose
fighter a data since adidas
gotta be quick got to be quick
gotta be quick get me off this thing get
me off this thing get me off this thing
get me off this thing get me off this
they give me out this thing get me off
this thing
Jesus
oh that's coming right at me oh boy well
that was close
holy God that was real close that was
super close this train is a real dick
let's go let's go let's move let's move
let's move
oh that was very close oh let's get out
of here bro oh I hate limpid charges I
refuse to use them yeah I know
Nike is the Nike is the goddess of
victory holy Christ
I got this I got this right here Oh your
mind baby
oh god damn son I'm gonna play The
Walking Dead Season three I have not but
I played the other two seasons they're
awesome I do we don't sleep front of
imagine if I was really here no you know
what I played paintball once and I died
so quick no joke it was like I would do
terrible in any kind of real combat
situation I think the dynamite might be
a mistake what I need is another
what's in here
oh I'll take that rocket gun reload we
gotta kill this porter's man oh jeez
I gotta like hold just run up to the
front of the Train it stabbed the driver
that's a great idea by the way oh
I think they've destroyed
whoa we're flying now
I'd see a field gun no one that's not
busted up how am I gonna get way up
there
yeah boy oh damn it
that's limpid charges what's this over
here
dynamite do I dare try to do dynamite oh
my god am I gonna try to whip a grenade
at this thing that's stupid
oh my look at the fighters let's do it
let's get crazy
holy schnikeys I'm getting railed right
now one more we got it come on damn it
oh my god this is insane
just throwing grenades at this day I
can't tell is isn't having any effect oh
that that that guns broken fall back
fall back fall back that's all barbed
wire over there that's all barbed wire
over there almost got this thing don't
make me use the limp at charge I hate
the limpid charges sir anything left in
anything oh now that music is going
crazy
what's in here wait there might be
something good in here Oh Rocky gun
that's exactly what I need alright
someone's about to get rocket guns there
are so many bad guys over there
oh that was a lucky shot
all right it's time for rocket gun
rocket gun time let's do it
that guy's coming up quick Jesus Christ
oh that guy stabbed that dude too late
those workers coming over here oh
they're real close
Jesus help
oh my god rocket gun rocket gun rocket
gun loaded loaded loaded loaded loaded
loading more rocket gun
damn dude I can hear you in the bathroom
all the Fantas on oh sorry zero viewers
go tell him
this is way too mainstream for me that
beat I got my number
I just got stabbed some dudes real quick
stabbed over oh yeah gotta stab as many
guys as possible in this game
oh that guy gets a stab and you know
what you're about to get stabbed that's
right
stabbed onto others as you would stab on
to yourself or whatever the phrase is I
don't say all right here we go
I have anything else I can throw [ __ ]
dude what else can I do
to shoot it with my gun
I'll make me use the limp in charges
Xbox one stabbing is so brutal I know
that this train is it you know what I
might have to go back into the town to
see if there's any other guns or
anything oh hey there's a field gun
right here
well oh there was a field gun they just
blew it up cool weapon crate what did I
get
oh we got it okay we're gonna end this
we're gonna end this the only way we we
know how by throwing a stupid grenade at
the dump thing let's go let's get up
there
I'm just like whipping I did it yes oh
god get back from the explosion oh and
then stings Desert Rose starts where's
my stabbing knife who a sweet or bitter
brew
how did we find it did we find it a
sweeter bitter brew
she looked at her knife she was like I
my Stabbin knife
I think he's talking about historical
stuff I don't know about
and it's quite a birthmark she's good
yeah windsock there's no music it's just
so yeah the beer I'm drinking is fresca
the best beer what hobbies do we have
well
besides playing video games crying in
the shower and eating chicken breasts
Thank You Nathan vlogs alright guys well
I think that's gonna do it for this this
stream Coco thank you for joining us it
was awesome
be sure to watch the show tonight viggo
mortensen Emily Heller and probably puss
sane or on the show this evening and
we're back with all new shows this for
the next couple weeks that's right so
stay tuned
we got good stuff coming up thank you
for joining us we will see you right
back here Monday next Monday at noon on
stream Coco see you guys later bye don't
be mad don't be mad don't be mad
you
you